-Hi. Oh, it's great to see --
-How are you?
-Hi, bud.
-It's great to see you both.
You look fantastic.
Thank you for doing this.
We have so much to talk about.
I just watched the documentary
last night,
and I was blown away.
"Siempre, Luis"
means "Always, Luis."
That is how you sign
all of your memos and letters?
-That's how I have signed
my entire life,
and so I'm very honored
that then Lin-Manuel
took all the "Siempre, Luis."
So the "Siempre, Lin-Manuel."
So now it'll live forever.
-It was -- The cameras
follow Luis around for a year.
And I was watching it.
And I, you know --
I know you guys pretty well.
I thought Lin had
a lot of energy.
Luis, you are nonstop.
-Well, that's what
some people say.
I'm energetic
but by no means nonstop.
I'm working on being nonstop.
-You're always doing something,
and it's -- I mean,
I know you have great energy
and just fun.
But, wow, the work you put in.
You came here from Puerto Rico,
and you came to New York City.
You worked on a number
of political campaigns.
You've always worked
to help people in times of need.
You get that from watching this.
And both of you are so active
in so many great causes.
Lin, is that something
you learned from your dad?
-Yeah, I think so.
It always just sort of
came with growing up.
Other kids had paper routes,
and I was registering voters
in buildings.
I was, like, the guy with the
green paper and the clipboard.
That was my -- That was
my teenage chore of choice.
-Wow!
-So it was --
And then
I also remember, like,
going to toy drives as a kid.
We always did the Three Kings'
Day toy drive every year
where we would get toys for kids
for Three Kings' Day.
So, yeah, there was always
sort of an activism
and sort of charity component
of growing up.
That just came with the deal
of living in our house.
-Luis, you were hoping
that Lin would be a lawyer.
Do you remember
the moment you knew
that he was going to
be a performer?
-Actually throughout my life,
I just pretended.
-Look how he shakes his head.
Just so...
-I continued pushing.
I figure I'll tire him out,
and he'll want to make me happy
and be like Rubén Blades
and also be a lawyer.
But it was actually one day
watching him on TV
that he was with a chorus,
a school performance,
where it was so clear
to my wife, Luz, and me
that this kid
was not going to be a lawyer,
as he was flapping his hands
and just being so animated.
-Yeah.
-I looked at Luz and said,
"He's never
going to be a lawyer."
Those skills of flapping hands
and stuff like that
can be helpful for legal.
-Flapping hands? That's my --
That's what I do for a living.
Flapping hands.
-"Your honor!
Your honor!
My client is innocent!"
-"I object!"
[ Laughter ]
-I mean -- Ohh.
-It was clear.
It was not happening.
-Yeah.
Lin, you tell a story
in the documentary
about the time
you asked your dad for advice
about your career.
What did you ask him?
-Yeah. I was --
My first job out of college
was teaching 7th-grade English,
and I found, to my surprise,
that I really liked it.
I loved teaching.
It's an incredibly rewarding
profession.
I think teachers should make,
like, all the money.
Like, I think we should just
reverse the way society works,
and teachers should get the
inverse of what they are making.
And -- But I loved it.
And I got offered
a full-time job
at the end of my first year,
and I kind of saw
two paths ahead of me.
I saw the
"Mr. Holland's Opus" path
where I live a happy life
teaching
but I never finish
that play I was working on.
And -- But I really --
I genuinely loved it.
And so I asked my dad,
"Should I take the full-time job
or should I sort of say no
to that and not have a job
but, you know,
have more time to write?"
And he actually sort of
nudged me in the direction
of pursuing my dream.
And I'll always be grateful
to him for that,
even though he was,
you know, just on my shoulder
to be a lawyer
all through high school,
he kind of realized
you actually have to go
for the thing you want.
-Luis, do you remember
writing that letter?
-I remember writing that letter.
And the advice came easy.
I knew it was
the right thing to do,
even though
I was smacking myself
for giving that advice.
-Flapping his arms!
-Parents should be saying,
"Go to work, go to work,
take a job."
But I knew
that was not his path.
He would've been
a great teacher.
He probably would have created
lots of Lin-Manuels
in that classroom,
but he would have not been
the Lin-Manuel we love.
-The one thing I took from it
is that the work is never over
and you just have to
just continue to wake up,
and you go, "Yeah,"
and you got to show up,
and you got to show up
for people
and stand up for people.
It was inspiring to watch.
Everyone should watch
"Siempre, Luis."
What do you want people
to take from it, Luis?
-Two things.
On the one hand,
that even though
the documentary is about me,
I'm really just a place holder
for migrants, immigrants
who come into this country
and have to work
the double shift
in order to move
their families forward.
And, two,
that my most important job,
it's being a dad.
That's how we live forever,
by being a good dad
and creating
the next generation,
that it's better than you.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's a look at "Siempre, Luis"
out on HBO and HBO Max
right now.
Check this out.
-If anything has come out
of Hurricane Maria
is that it has
brought together...
[ Speaking Spanish ]
...our allies in the
United States with Puerto Rico.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And now, together,
we cannot be stopped!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They're living in a hotel.
They're looking for a place.
They're looking for jobs.
They're looking for schools
for their kids.
And on top of that,
we're telling them,
"Oh, [bleep].
And this is
a historical election.
And you got to be involved."
[ Speaking Spanish ]
-"Siempre, Luis"
is on HBO and HBO Max now.